Do you think because it infuriates me all right.
It infuriates me.
I, it broke my heart. It breaks my heart to get,
to get my special pastor and broke my heart in hindsight is the best thing that
ever happened to me because.
I'm gonna let you know Steve is, is that, I'll just say it.
I was pitching a show at Netflix with Joe coy and the,
and how we Mendell is with us because he's producing the thing that joke
and how he's like these two are very good stand-ups and the executives in the
room looked at me and they go, you do stand up to me.
And this is seven, eight months ago. Okay.
My heart cracked into my body and it melted into my soul. Right.
My point is, is that don't take it personally, right? That they passed on it.
I mean, of course I, you know, take it personally,
even the guy who's in charge of buying comedy
specialists at Netflix even went so far as to, uh,
to explicitly say, I am a comedy snob.
And I only am interested in buying comedy specials from lifelong pure standup
comedians of which I do not consider Steve-O to be. So it's like, Hey man,
I got to at least give them credit for not sugarcoating.
Hey, you. But you know, you right up your. But,
but, uh, but, but Hey man, at least you, at least you just said what it was.
And now I doubled down, I did the, the bucket list tour.
I just went all out now.
Now like one of my bucket list ideas was to go skydiving.
Butt-naked when the guys strapped on my back, the tandem dude,
while I'm jacking off and time it to that,
I'm falling out of the airplane, blowing alone all over everybody. Yeah.
And I did it.
It's called sky jacket. Okay.
Okay. [inaudible] let me ask you something because it's like,
if I'm masturbating, right. And I hear a little Creek, right.
Or a little wind, I get thrown off and imagine.
A plane full of dudes, all pointing cameras at you. How do you,
did you take Viagra? I took four Cialis tablets. Yeah. Here we go. Right.
Did you watch porn? Yeah. I brought a portable DVD.
That was my [inaudible]. That was the one exception. Well,
because you're not going to get a wifi signal. 15,000 feet. Wait,
do you start drinking off in the plane? How long before the jump, um,
jump did this was the craziest part about it was that
like I had to,
there's a window of like,
was it two minutes window?
Where like, it's got to happen.
You got to leave the plane within that two minutes.
Otherwise you're not going to be over the drop zone. So I had to time it dude.
Oh my God. I had to time it, it had to, so I was like, okay,
give me three minutes. Notice,
give me one minute before the two minutes starts.
So they screamed T-minus three and I start going for it, man. Like,
uh, Oh yeah. And then dude, like I,
it was happy, dude. It was, it was, it was the most as far as like multimedia,
like where it's like a funny story to try and find the company that would sign
off on it. Trying to find the guy who was willing to be strapped to my back,
trying to logistically pull it off in a plane full of dudes. I actually,
how it happened,
like the most hilarious stand-up comedy bit and the footage to back it up is
just next level. But that's,
that's one of the many things I did for the bucket list tour.
And that was all happened while I was just sitting on the gnarly special.
Wow. I was just sitting on it and I was like, trying to figure it out. Like,
okay, now how am I going to do know I spent so much money on it.
I can't just give it away. And even if I wasn't planning to give it away,
I can't put it on YouTube.
It won't last 60 seconds on there before they take it down. And you know,
and so it took me this long and only like just very recently, it just went up.
I'm figuring out the paywall, you know, it's streaming at Steve-O dot com and,
and to promote it, I bought a billboard and right here in Hollywood, wow.
I hired a crew like a,
a construction crew that builds gas stations with two cranes that,
you know, I'll even tell you how much the billboard costs,
8,000 bucks just to rent a billboard.
And then two cranes, a whole construction crew.
They built this thing for me to stand on, like flew out, uh,
this killer photographer, the whole leg. And I hired a publicist of like,
you know, like at the end, by the time I got done, like getting the special out,
like I was totally $300,000 into, wow.
And now I'm going to do this billboard stunt where let's face it.
There a pretty strong chance that, uh,
I'm going to have to hire another criminal attorney.
And.
The expenses are just going to get overwhelming. And I'm like,
it, dude. I'm going to show those
who rejected this thing.
I'm going to make them going to force them to deal with the
entire world. Knowing about mine gnarly special.
And I went up and then I got duct taped to that billboard. And within 48 hours,
I had articles online from variety,
vanity fair, rolling stone, TMZ,
Buzzfeed deadline, CNN people, extra.
He online USA today. the whole,
God world knows about my gnarly comedy special.
And um, they, the cops,
all the people they showed up and they looked at us and they said, Oh, well,
there was no crime being committed here. He taped to his own billboard.
Yeah. He bought the thing like, which is crazy. And, and,
and I did have a lawyer go over the contract with the billboard company and it's
their dumb,
no language whatsoever about anything to do with that.
Plus the they approved,
which was on the billboard was an image of me duck taped to the billboard.
All we did was duct tape me over for me.
Oh yeah. So they approved the art. Oh,
we didn't change. Yeah. Change the, the, the, uh,
approved image changed at all.
Since there's no crime here by what happened.
And that was upsetting to me was that the, uh,
the fire department shows up right now. We kept our two cranes.
They're called cherry picker cranes.
You see like the phone company guys in them, you know, it's like a little thing.
And, uh, we kept them on site so that we could take me down ourselves.
Like I didn't want to be involved in wasting the city's resources, you know,
like, and so I had my construction team on site with the cranes.
When the first responders showed up, they went straight over. They said, Hey,
there's nothing to worry about here.
He's on there with like five points of harness carabiners
clipped on the, the shelf.
He's standing on his like suspended by straps that are rated for over
5,000 pounds of weight. Like he's, he's on there. We've got cranes.
We can get them down. No problem. We don't want to waste your time.
The fire department sadly said,
we have to be the ones to get up for liability issues.
We've got to take them down. And I'm like, Oh, this is what I didn't want.
And when I heard that they have to take me down. I'd like,
I got them to send me up at night. I cut away the tape. I was like, Hey guys,
come on. Let's. And I did legitimately feel like,
like a piece of for having the fire department working on,
getting me down from my billboard. So what I did was I took, uh, uh,
the dopest photo that,
that photographer I hired and flew out the dopest photo that he took.
And I had it like cleaned up so that there wasn't a bunch of loud shin,
dope print. I bought a thousand of them. And, uh,
I saw them on my website for $25 a piece signed,
everyone signed all thousand,
went with within less than 48 hours. Yeah.
And that was $25,000 raised,
which I matched with my own $25,000 for a
total of $50,000 that today I donated to the Los
Angeles fire department. Cool man. Yeah. So it's like, kind of like,
I got to clean up my mess a little bit on the only part of the plan that sucked.
The one thing that tainted this Epic publicity stunt was the fire department
showed up in and had to waste their time on me.
And so I donated 50 grand to them today.
And that was the last I was driving. I was,
I posted the while I was driving here. I hate to be texting and driving.
I was grabbing dude. I grabbed my picture of me with the fire chief dude,
holding up this obnoxious oversight and on the check I'm.
Duct tape. Yeah.
I'm so stoked on it, man. And, um, United starts.
So I feel good about that part of it and, and. Yeah,
like here and dad, I shouldn't even like, I should just let it be,
but, but the thing is that the,
everybody who rejected my special,
the quarter million part that I spent producing it, I mean,
I'll just say I sat on the thing for two and a half years.
I taped it in January of 2018. Wow.
So come all this time later,
that quarter million it's been out the door so long ago,
I don't even consider it missing. You know, I was like, dude,
anything I get for this from distributing it on my own website.
It's all bonus. It's all gravy. I think you'll get it back.
I already had it back by the time I was on the billboard.
And, and uh, and I,
I already had brought in over $300,000 in revenue
by the time that the cherry picker cranes went up with the curve that attached
me to the billboard. And, um, that,
that was when I'd started kicking more
because of the whole world knew about it and them,
not the fire department. everybody didn't believe in this.
I want to ask you a question though.
Yeah. And, and, and you know what, like I'll even say, I'm crazy to say this.
I don't, you know, like, uh,
if people stream streaming for nine 99 at Steve-O dot com.
See right now he's our boy. I love him so much. He's so funny.
go to his website and stream gnarly.
Yeah, no, like I hired the same anti-piracy company that all the movie
studios hire, you know, like they, they just said, candidly,
it's not possible to completely scrub it away.
If people are really determined to, to watch it for free, they will.
And if people don't want and don't have nine 99 and they want to them up by all
means, go for it. But I did everything in my power to make that difficult,
to make it just easier to pay the nine 99. I would appreciate it if people did,
because I really have, I have a ax to grind and, and,
and you know,
the other thing how my first special was all about journey to
learn how to have a healthy relationship.
The last thing that happened on stage at this, on this new, special,
the gnarly special,
the last thing that happens on that stage is I get on my knee and I proposed to
my girl in front, Oh, family and friends. When does the wedding?
We don't have a date yet because we're,
we're determined to buy a property and open up our own animal sanctuary,
EV we're going to get married on that Khalilah. And I invited to the wedding.
Absolutely. We are going to go 100%. Absolutely.
It might be the only wedding I look forward to just because it's an animal
sanctuary.
We're not having kids because one of my bucket list items was called the
vasectomy Olympics. It's tied up,
add snipped it's knit.
You can extract from the balls extract from the balls. You can't extract it.
I don't know. I think you should have children. No,
I honestly think it would be a good, great father. Listen,
because look at how far you've come.